[Musique]
stable
m
[Musique]
mr maria pour nous c'est à la fois en
figure de proue de l'immigration russe
et héros de la résistance et surtout sa
mort réflète toute sa vie je pense que
toute sa vie s approchait vers ce moment
quand elle a sauvé quelqu'un et a donné
sa vie quelques mois avant la victoire
elle a été résistant sans hésiter elle a
été de sedan l'émigration qui ont choisi
leur camp sans hésiter bien qu'ancienne
et sert bien conscient nancy poursuivi
qu elle a opté pour le bon principe
anglais marquent un traître ranque mon
pays que les raisons ou pas et on a
combattu un homme dans la mesure de ses
forces et l'a combattu le nazisme
ce en quoi elle a été notamment autant
que possible et dépendant défunt père
[Musique]
qui